my pillow uh CEO and founder Mike
Lindell known colloquially as pillow
almost like Cher or Madonna or Kanye
maybe for a better example he is now
running for chairman of the Republican
National Committee
this is absolutely the best this guy is
increasingly cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs and
I can think of no more logical choice to
run such a Nutty party than Mike pillow
here he is on real America's voice we're
still trying to figure out what that is
explaining he's running this here is to
is a hundred percent all in I've seen a
big the RNC is one of the most important
organizations in our country and it's
sinking the ship is going down and it's
you know it needs a leader and it needs
a business leader it needs someone that
knows how to fix things by the way
can we be done with we need a business
person to lead the country here there or
the other place prior to Trump we really
didn't have any examples of business
people making good presidents we now
have had a business person president one
of the worst disasters that I can
remember
and now they want to do it again in
another position I mean listen if you
want to ruin your party would that go
for it it's not making too much sense to
me how to be proactive in moving forward
with a change in Footprints our foot the
footprint of our country has drastically
changed it it's went all over the board
things that things that you thought that
you could always count on you can't
count on anymore you can't you know and
uh so no this is a hundred percent
um a need and believe me people came to
me that sort of perspark this these were
big donors and when the big donors are
going to leave and when they are in C
when you have all its own members going
hey we want to
um your donors aren't given and uh and
your and your party is going to crumble
and it would it's already you can't if
they don't have a plan of something
different coming in a different input
you're gonna get the same output Steve
so I say to that you want you want to
make this you you want to succeed uh you
get you get me elected uh to the all
these states where you know one of those
168 people that I'm going to call each
and every one of them yeah okay so
listen pillows running is this just what
Republicans need is he in a sense the
most logical choice I hope that this
happens I think it would be an absolute
disaster for the Republican Party one of
the I am not a fan in any way of of Rona
Rona McDaniel Ronald McDaniel uh but at
least she was from the wing that
sometimes would realize hey you know
it's probably not great for us for Trump
to come to Georgia to help Herschel
Walker he's probably doing more damage
than than helping at this point in time
she had some connection to reality in
terms of Maga even if I find her
politics completely deplorable pillow is
a guy who will go what we need is Trump
we need Trump everywhere we need
lawsuits everywhere we need to talk
about how we won every election that we
actually lost and we know how that
turned out for them in 2022 so I welcome
Mike pillow running here